hi this is Natalie Villalobos from big
Android BBQ in hurst texas and i'm here
with maurice whites she is a visiting
designer she's speaker here at big
Android BBQ and I wanted to just get
some inside tips so that all designers
of the world know how to best design for
Android welcome Marie hi so can you tell
us a little bit about how you got into
design I was a front-end developer i
earned my little money with HTML and you
know markup and I try to get to
University at that point agencies were
too interested in me and I already got a
job as designer because I had too much
telling for that yeah so what was your
first successful project what is
successful well you can be challenging
but I thought successful might have a
favor you with my first successful
project was I think on Android with a
hacker community in Berlin blinkin droid
I helped them to clean up the interface
and we had world record I think a world
where they holding a world record for
the hackathon or maybe apps built no
blink android is an application where
phones build a huge mosaic of tiny
displays and they built the biggest one
so I just helped them to clean up what
was that can you tell us what the mosaic
image was of I think an image of our
hacker space in Berlin ok so not like
the Mona Lisa not like the Mona Lisa
alright just as cool how many people
participate in the hacker community in
Berlin oh I can't say I mean because its
presidential or not not as confidential
it's too huge if you take for instance
if you take the series in Berlin they
have 500 members and from 500 members
hundred are active per week you don't
know how many members are actually
living and yeah working in will in got
it and so if a designer were wanting to
start building for Android or just
stepping into their career what are some
of the tips and tricks that you would
give a designer that's just getting
started I would say try to befriend your
colleagues because collaboration is all
you have to learn and very often
designers stay in their own comfort zone
and in their own space and the best you
can do is pick your colleagues mind and
start learning about the technology
itself you don't have to code it but you
have to learn what it is and I think
that's the best advice I can give to
young designers yeah I absolutely agree
on the collaboration practices so
designers are integral to the process of
creating a beautiful mobile app or I
think really any successful technology
project may I think a lot of times
developers and software engineers don't
really know that right just how yeah how
integral you are to the success I mean a
designer has a empathy rule in a team he
is using a lot of empathy to design and
create and he's using empathy to
communicate so that's some sort of part
of our job I think yeah
and so your talk yesterday was a bit
about creating beautiful user beautiful
and intuitive user experiences can you
tell us a little bit about your talk and
what you wanted the audience to walk
away with okay I was talking about
animation for interfaces and very often
I get okay that's too expensive that's
too complicated we should do it later
when time is left and my point is that's
the wrong approach it's one of the most
important and powerful tools we have and
it's not very complicated to do and I
was showing my audience how to do it
with just pen and paper and they
shouldn't be afraid and I had a lot of
developers in my talk so I was
encouraging them to join the topic and
be designers and do interaction design
so and I you know one of the points that
you hit on was really that anyone can
animate and I think that the the
prototyping element of what you were
gifting to the audience was really
important I think a lot of people can
feel overwhelmed with being an artist
right if it maybe that's not their first
calling so do you have any tips of like
overcoming that fear yes and no
overcoming I mean being a good artist is
something about practice practice
practice and I was just recently asked
how did you became good as you are right
now and I just said stubbornness
stubbornness stubbornness stubbornness
you have to practice that's how it is
and all I can say is don't be afraid of
failing because in every discipline you
have to fail and if you look at great
artist you can see they have their time
to
so look at them look deeply and ask them
they will encourage you that's what I
can promise do you think that having a
more beautiful well designed intuitive
app will lead to more successful apps
and therefore more money for developers
um it happened I just know that works
yeah so this is what ever tell Mike
lines I just say it you know what if you
want to have more money we need to do
this that's just how it is last time no
I really appreciate so I guess that's
really the pro tip right is like
incorporating design and I think a lot
of the principles that you touched on
yesterday in your talk which is online
somewhere right yes okay great so I
think if if people look at your
principles they too can incorporate
design from a prototyping side bring it
into development and then long-term you
know they'll be more successful as
developers because of a lot of the
legends more successful what I say is
throwing all the technology you have
into your application doesn't make it
better and it doesn't make a cheaper to
develop it makes it more expensive I was
picking on the name mean meaningful make
it meaningful and as soon you have a
meaningful application and a meaningful
design you can have less development
time less cost and still the same
success so it's i would say optimization
it's are you for hire like if people
want to bring three lenses all right so
you know hopefully the developers of the
world reach out to you can you tell us
your twitter handle and where we can see
more about your work I'm reachable on G+
as Maurice rights that's hard work what
is your website my website is DB suy com
so my brand is diversity and yeah that's
how I'm reachable and where you can find
my talk awesome well thanks so much for
sitting down with us today and
thank you so much for flying all the way
from Germany to be here big enterprise
do it's a pleasure thank you so again
this is Natalie Villalobos sitting here
with Mary Schweitzer successful
freelance interaction and visual
designer who's visiting us here at big
Android BBQ stay tuned we're going to
have more great interviews coming up
soon